[Music]
the studio is my bitch I will always
protect it whenever evil comes I will
defend her the shit is that she is my
studio to put my hand up her skirt as I
please see what the dick sauce is that
Hello critic let's kick this reviews ass
in the sexiest way possible first of all
that's not sexy
that's scary scary sexist Gary scary
second what the perverted Mounties
mother Falcon is going on I don't know I
thought I'd switch things up today so I
hired a new director Frank Miller wait
crazy-cool Frank Miller just crazy Frank
Miller I don't know which one is that
incredible my fetish goddess but you do
show off the swastika and your outfit no
wait you got the plain crazy one hey hey
you don't know maybe this is somehow all
brilliant what are you dense what are
you retarded or something do you know
who the hell I am I'm goddamn Frank
Miller
it's just crazy uh prove it hello crazy
cool Frank Miller - hi I think we got
the plain crazy version of you ah okay
well there's only one way to know for
sure asking these questions got it
hey Frank damn why are you in color I
don't know why she dressed like that
I don't know what does a it does have to
do with the source material I don't
goddamn know yep he answered the same -
all of them - I knew it that's totally
crazy me the best thing to do is not
give him any attention for the love of
God keep him as far away from Gimli as
possible right I don't get it I thought
Frank Miller was one of the most
influential storytellers of our time
well he is you know I really should draw
the Joker more like Plastic Man and
Captain Planet more often was Frank
Miller was one of the biggest names if
not the biggest name and getting people
to realize comic books could be for
adults with his reinvention of classic
characters like daredevil and Batman
Ghora fiying his own gritty style with
Sin City and 300 an even inspiring
blockbuster hit some of which he himself
directed this was one hell of a creative
force to admire and that's um where he
went cuckoo bananas Scott
damn cuckoo-bananas it keeps you far
away from me yes I can't promise that
both Millard writing and artwork seem to
suffer greatly due to nobody really
knows and it's practically a cliché now
to mock the insanity of his later works
whether he just went nuts or was always
nuts and just hit it better nobody could
deny there was a train too out of your
damn minds Ville and he was the one in
the driver's seat and one of his
crowning achievements of bonkers dumb is
the spirit based on the forties comic by
Will Eisner the spirit tries to go for
old-school charm in Satan's school of
ethics so many bizarre choices that
nobody but Miller could follow make this
an uncomfortable unfeeling and
unrecognizable adaptation of what should
be an upbeat adventure with just a hint
of misogyny and racism
hey maybe Miller was a good choice to
direct this regardless many agreed not
only did it not capture what the
original source material was about but
the directions it goes in seem to have
no rhyme or reason whatsoever
are they right well strap on your masks
that don't seem to hide shit this is the
spirit the film opens dead on arrival
flat lining on us while the credits roll
I dad damn death is a hottie I know the
ladies got Brad Pitt but this ain't a
bad alternative for guys I play strip
chess with you any day it turns out this
is a vision the Spirit is having as
death stalks him a lot through this
movie because apparently death has
nothing better to do the let's be honest
a woman stalking Gabriel Maude is
probably something he's used to yeah
something big is breaking down let him
what flat spirit word on the street is
the octopus might be in on it
okay problem number one your villain is
called octopus stung even films as goofy
as spider-man two new to : Doc Ock
because you can take the name octopus as
seriously as you can take the name
Pazuzu the octopus octopus octopus
octopus octopus Pazuzu the zoo zoo zoo
zoo zoo zoo zoo zoo zoo he don't even
give him a reason why he's called that
through most of the film this is calling
card tentacle hentai
trust me with this film's tone that
would totally fit who knows how far is
tentacle spread the spirit goes rooftop
hopping about as convincing as Mario
maker as he monologues about his city
like it's the milf he's been waiting for
all his life my city she's not some
target a fraud all dressed up like a
piece of jailbait no she's an old city
old and proud of her every pocket
crackin link she's my sweetheart my
plaything
okay so he goes on and on throughout the
film about how weirdly orality is by
this place but what makes it so funny if
the writing is so bad and so incoherent
it could just as easily come from the
tick seriously listen to these lines and
imagine him saying it she's not some
tarted-up fraud all dressed up like a
piece of jailbait no she's an old city
old and proud of her every puck and
crack and wrinkle she's my sweetheart my
plaything honestly not convinced this
whole thing isn't just one big tick
episode he doesn't even move that
gracefully
he jumps like a drunk swimmer who
doesn't know he's on dry land he comes
across a damsel in distress being mugged
and saves her just in time
I am shit this film so unfocused even I
forgot
well this is an awkward filmmaking Joe
can you answer for me
that's the spirit thank you Joe she
provides for me my city does he gives me
see especially this shot that Miller
really seems to have a hard-on for the
officer who called the spirit sees the
best makeup to stay on underwater ever
as he shot and the woman goes back on
there to complete a robbery again
totally underwater not just a fan in a
studio that also keeps gelled hair
perfect trust me don't be the least of
your concerns when you see Samuel Speedy
Gonzales in a - the film mother fuck
mother F of mother F oh oh by the way
I'm saying mother effer because get this
you're watching a pg-13 Frank Miller
film yeah this film noir has literally
no are so Miller can't even go all the
way with his door which was always a big
draw with his work even the decapitated
cop played by Miller gets the puss out
treatment and that's a shame because
there's a lot of wonder woman fans would
love to see that scene in more detail I
think a lot of them are tired of
rewinding this scene worth killing for
the octopus play by Jackson starts
fighting the spirit while his henchwoman
named silken floss played by Scarlett
just two more years till I do real comic
book movies Hansen is nevertheless still
giving this performance one hundred
percent up the box and pile and
specimens you've done your petri dishes
proud eighty percent no need to wait for
the boss if that's the spirit back there
okay doing your fifty percent but he
pretended to pretend over here dying
here 40 40 40 percent the octopus always
finds his nemesis so distracting 14
enjoy new 30 30 percent 31 it was just
getting started I'm sure she can coast
even more after the third rising out of
the water shot I'd asked if Miller's
aroused by that bun just assuming
everything arouses him as I continued to
pg-13 the shit out of each other
apparently nothing can destroy these two
and they don't seem to feel pain at
least they don't act like they do so
what should be awesome is basically a
boring itchy and scratchy cartoon where
no one gets hurt
oh no enough like a cartoon get a load
of this got it well at least they're
visually representing the craft they're
in usually that mathematical equation is
correct but once again Miller it's
really challenging the art of shit
nothing like you nothing like me
actually we have no idea we're 16
minutes in and we have no idea what the
spirit is like I know he wants to fondle
the city but if anything that makes me
want to know even less about him he
passes out and wakes up to a doctor
named Ellen treating his wounds for
God's sake you can't keep taking these
chances I'll be fine something in my
question by the way is the use of color
in black and white and one of NOAA's
other films Sin City it's used very
cleverly a woman named Goldie is
literally gold and she has a twin sister
who the main character confuse it for
her shown through color there's a man
who's supposed to stand out like mad
because he's yellow and in a black and
white world that really stands out an
assassin says this woman's colored eyes
tells him she's running and has to
accept her fate he kills her and by the
end comes across a main character with
colored eyes who also has to face the
same fate it felt like there was an
instinctual reason for the color even
but wasn't fully explained here the
color seems beyond random anyone can
have shades of color on them for no
reason help the black and white looks
more like brown and white half the time
so the color isn't even as eye-catching
as it should be I feel like I'm watching
the opening of Wizard of Oz except that
yellow bastards not only gonna show up
in fact this Newsies flashback he has
looks like it's been filtered in dog
piss it's being a witch in this
flashback he knew a girl named
sans-serif' sounds like a font nobody
uses who dreams of one day surrounding
herself and material goods but his Uncle
Pete gets in trouble accidentally
shooting sans dead who happens to be a
cop before taking his own life so kids
just how does this make you feel
I hate cars well that's confusing you
didn't mean what you said leave me alone
and just stay away please give it a
while what what us yeah that's what I
mean is now really the time to talk
about relationship goals it even shed a
tear when your uncle died doesn't know
what happened he wasn't there and then
some punched out drunk of an old boxer
suits you dead what's it Pete it was
that Guido and you know that that nobody
else saw including me
he just looks like he was shot in a
greeter way I'm gonna go over the world
and I'm gonna become rich but do
whatever you wants and I don't care
about you neither I never even want to
see you again yeah that's right you
don't you read I hope that works out for
you you and your red but deep in the
sewers we see samurai l.jackson and
scarlet kimono hansen are disappointed
that his clone experiments brought back
the wrong case i am sorely disappointed
all right you said his listening to me
fine sensor find her now so Frank oh
yeah
Jesus okay I'll admit I don't know much
about the spirit but I google the spirit
and samurai and nothing came up though I
did find out katanas backstory and
surprisingly there is more to her than
she's got your back critic if you can't
see why a film noir crime fighter
wouldn't use a samurai you also probably
can't see why calling someone apart it's
a great insult that's clearly not a
great really I use it in the movie
what other box you fart dude what are
you four years old
no I'm this many times Tom well God you
gave him attention don't you he's got
Samuel Jackson's a samurai in the spirit
I'm sorry I needed some explanation
critic it's not worth it you know the
one thing he can give you that's more
terrifying than no explanation what an
explanation oh Christ you're right just
close your eyes and think about how
awesome the movie 300 was it was very
awesome in fact it was so good maybe
that director should also handle my
version of Batman the more they think
about don't do that I gotta go having
fun I'm confused what life choices
brought me here
sans-serif' now played by Eva Mendes is
searching for an ancient treasure
because no joke it's a shiny thing the
shiny thing and oh anything
dames and bling she blackmails the
philanthropist who betrayed her with
incriminating pictures and forces him to
hand over all his money then I swear to
every known god I am NOT making this up
she Xeroxes her ass on the copy machine
imagine my surprise when I show up at
the drop point and ran smack into the
oculus making a perfect ass of yourself
dames and mimeograph posteriors for
posterity he shoots himself after losing
all his money while the spirit gets
friendly with the doctor from before
what's on your agenda tonight I don't
know
dinner movie anything you know for a guy
who made fun of the Adam West Batman a
lot he sure is willing to have this dark
and gritty superhero reenact Archie
comics would this be more Betty Ann
Veronica I don't know I don't read them
and I thought he did the spirit promises
he'll be loyal to her but the father
from Wonder Years has other plans
hey freakazoid want to get a yogurt it's
an honor to meet you mr. spirit I'm
Morgenstern rookie fresh from Baum war
nah just kidding I'm obviously a
stripper but Ellen sees he's in love
with every woman he meets I don't know
why she's shocked she literally just
said that
and he even manages to flirt with the
reporters and for the ladies you know we
hang on your every word thanks for being
such amazing
lovely creatures no to life allow me to
fix my mask to protect the secret
identity I don't have that go to the
philanthropist who killed himself but
the spirit recognizes that ass and shows
it around town to see if anyone else
recognizes it oh that's not a joke that
goddamn happens he literally shows the
picture of the ass to ID her
the only thing stupider than that a
little person recognizes it get it cuz
he's small but knowing Frank Miller
every criminal Linna probably looks like
this tell me this can't possibly get any
dumber
I think that's plain damn weird yes sir
just plain damn weird Frank I want to
ask what the point of this was I want to
ask why you thought taking while your
little clone minions and turning him
into a tiny foot was necessary to learn
more about the characters or story but
I'm afraid if I give you any attention
or even look at you you're just gonna
use that attention to act more friggin
insane am i right I was right turn away
from him and never cut back
[Applause]
[Music]
so the spirit fine sand via blood
identification but she's stepping out of
the shower with her hair made up and not
the least bit wet put a robe on or
something but no tricks it's stolen oh
yeah huh she just slipped that on huh
it's not something you toss on that's
something you glue on it looks like she
found the treasured vase with the blood
the octopus was looking for but she toss
it the spirit out proving once again
what a Columbia Mass we're supposed to
be rooting for he's so embarrassing even
the movie starts to reject him isn't
this like pointing out that Batman's
head kind of looks like a spork do you
really want to actively make yourself
look more lame and believe it or not it
gets even lamer
[Music]
why do I feel like this is healthy find
Miller every Thursday night he gets a
leave though and heads over to the
octopus's hideout well the enemy has his
gun two knives I have an entire city as
my weapon well snow is more part of the
elements but whatever gets you in the
city to third base he jumps in the sewer
and comes across Johansen could this be
a trap
no no it's just a woman who's dressed
nice in the sewer who wants to make out
with you all why do was a trap you know
this guy's like Dick Tracy except you
take out the Tracy so you have his dick
mean well Elenin heard ed discuss her
future with the spirit because that's
what we want to see when the heroes in
peril he's a goddamn menace and my own
daughters in love with him it was so
much happier in the old days with Denny
yeah he was pretty charming you look
beautiful today can I kiss you wait no
he was disturbed you know death is there
really nothing better you can do there's
no bill and ted movie you can cameo in
spirit wakes up tied to a chair as
outcomes I don't know a belly dancer
el martes and starts dancing for him
because now I think we can jump to the
conclusion that all of this film is just
for Millers personal video collection he
just wanted to see if he can make money
off of it to pee as he could
[Music]
sure for an hour in might as well start
talking to the camera now and just when
you think that's this movie so bad that
actually stops your thinking
but just when your thinking starts to
return I don't know a pile of
psychedelic frogs they set on fire and
inhaled but its effects are clearly
standing before you Samuel Jackson is
now a Nazi for no conceivable reason
whatsoever and he has to go along with
it like it makes all the sense in the
world to him to eat so we won't die we
mate so that our seed will live on just
look at Johansen throughout this scene
she's totally dead inside even she can't
believe she's standing where she is next
to who she's with wearing what she's
wearing how the hell did Miller convince
Jackson to do this I was kind of
expecting Malcolm to come out to do
something as Samuel Jackson Anna yeah
he's out of town this weekend ah that's
right I totally forgot well maybe we can
get solos to play no that's a bad idea
I'm just gonna give him a call Malcolm
can you play Samuel Jackson as a Nazi
sure wonderful I got Frank Miller here
and crazy cool Frank Miller just plain
crazy Frank Miller okay and he's gonna
act out the scene with you go Sam Jackie
baby I want you to wear a Nazi uniform
cracker you out of your damn mind but
it'll be great satire and that nobody
will understand it so nobody will
question it you must be damn crazy if
you okay you know what this doesn't feel
right how could you possibly make him
goose-step you must be damn crazy if you
think I'm gonna do this snakes on a
plane had more dignity I'd rather do
another
credit-card you know what that's not
feeling right either do you feel the
scene needs more foot people I feel it
needs more foot people as anyone else
feel like this needs more foot people
but now my taking direction from you I
ask that every shoe
shut up Malcolm this seems so crazy no
sketch could possibly capture its
madness I bet my sketch could I've
really gone downhill as an artist you
know dammit and where'd you find him
anyway sucking air out of my tires we
discovered the spirits backstory as he
was originally a shot-up rookie cop
named Denny but he was given the same
invincible formula octopus took so he
came back from the dead and visited
Ellen's father on something else now I
could be the city's protector it's it's
spirit
now that's due but I was gonna say
zombie Jesus so wait if Ellen's dad
knows the spirit is Denny why does he
talk nice about Denny but hate the
spirit this films as consistent as
golems wedding vows octopus says once he
drinks he releases blood he'll become
immortal a god and for no reason at all
he kills a cat named oven wasn't weird
enough this is the only character spirit
actually get emotional about muffin the
cat she is all the reason I need I will
kill you even Jackson is like really
that's what dinner fire didn't you uncle
die and your cop friend look this is the
one that sent you over the edge
it's pression that's not bad mouth
progress it is the only pussy he ever
gave a shit about so the belly dancer is
gonna chop him up and separate his body
but he speaks French that's apparently
enough to win somebody over Pepe LePew
is clearly doing something wrong if
that's all it takes to get a woman
and this one's for muffin its muffin
your fiancee what is up with this
relationship just as sporadic as the
belly dancer saving him the belly dancer
also stabs him in the back apparently
saying it's force and I don't frickin
follow it but I did just see Samuel
Jackson his Colonel Klink so I should
really be used to not getting answers
this is followed by Guess Who I am sick
to you of you at least this time spirit
thinks of calling it in and giving up
two deaths horny embrace but then he
remembers any woman he kisses he has to
abandon so he leaves death once more no
they need me you want to escape me I am
the man slut
he wakes up in the hospital though with
Ellen again tending to his wounds oh
gosh hey freakazoid when I go out for a
minute somebody get me a tie it sure as
hell better be red no shirt just a tie
it
add to my horniness he comes up with a
plan to catch the octopus who is meeting
up with San to collect the vase nobody
goes anyway face please protecting what
Jackson's gonna look like in every scene
is like predicting will costume Bugs
Bunny's gonna wear guaranteed laughable
and for some reason nobody questions it
the spirit shows up with the cops and
the octopus try shooting him even though
he knows it does nothing is that why
he's called that no examples of it
before I mean he has eight Nazi uniforms
eight sombreros ain't afro samurai
cosplays I think it would actually make
more sense to call him the hateful eight
the cats come in though leading to this
really weird shot
I gotta give them credit for finding new
and creative ways to explore stupid but
the rookie cop fires her big-ass gun at
him causing smoke debris that's shaped
like an octopus it's symbolic because
this movie's blowing smoke up your ass
spirit and sand deliver the finishing
bad effect and they give a victory kiss
right in front of Ellen
[Music]
well who me 20 times shame on you fool
me 21 times I still love him yes that
was just a goodbye eating her mouth and
feeling her up kiss it means nothing
like this movie
[Music]
hey freakazoid want to go see a bear
ride a motorcycle
yes sir give me this one Dolan just let
her go so of course he tries to explain
himself once again to Ellen do you have
a baby with all my heart that's not true
hey baby you are amazing
and yeah that's pretty much where it
ends he admits once more that no one can
have his heart but the city his dick is
another story but his heart belongs to
architecture I could never give my heart
to anyone her she owns me body and soul
she is the love of my life
muffin my city bullshit your muffins
bitch and you know it and that was the
spirit by God I pray the comic was
nothing like ask it looks nice I guess
but all I can think about is how much it
looks like Sin City which doesn't match
whatever the hell tone or style this
movie is going for every character is
either an archetype or has no real
identity I don't know why the spirit
does what he does I don't know why the
octopus does what he does nobody has any
real motivation the characters and
therefore the film have no reason to
exist they're just we're puppets that do
weird things for a seemingly no reward
Frank Miller has been a game changer in
the past and hopefully is work in the
near future will again reflect that but
as from material like this it's unlikely
it's gonna be inspiring many anytime
soon
I'm gonna stop your credit I remember
why did you do that I don't know I am
death I have come oh I have come to come
and take you into the afterlife
you know you could do this a lot easier
if you just turn off the fan behind you
whoa that is better
oh my god I have no idea why I've been
using that thing for so long
Thank You critic so you can pretty
obvious as a reward I will not came and
grant you one request I kiss next week
I'd like to review the anti version of
this film you know a superhero who's
also invincible is supposed to be funny
breaks the fourth wall however this one
will be in a big hit and it would still
be challenging to review can it have a
Celine Dion so
[Music]
[Applause]
and this one's for muffin
hi Doug Walker here doing the charity
shot on this week we are doing Coalition
for the homeless this is the nation's
oldest advocacy and direct service
organization helping homeless men women
and children they believe that
affordable housing sufficient food and
the chance to work for a living wage are
fundamental rights in a civilized
society since their inception in 1981
the Coalition has worked through
litigation public education and direct
services to ensure that these goals are
realized their effectiveness to rise
from their unique role as both an
efficacy and direct service organization
their programs shelter monitoring and
grassroots organizing and able them to
meet homeless people where they are as
well as giving a voice and hope to the
most marginalized among us if you look
at their site in their YouTube page
you'll see all the ways that their
efficacy is informed by the very real
daily struggles of our homeless
neighbors and seek practical humane
cost-effective long-term solutions
proven to work click on the link and see
how much you can do for those who have
so little
you
[Music]